it's time for the launching from esco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour tour show you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chroma scope mister william
bradford huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. donald i Roger as an
editor of the New York Herald Tribune
our distinguished guest for this evening
is dr. Jules Backman professor of
economics New York University the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers dr. Backman is one of
the nation's leading experts on wages
and prices and as a former consultant of
the office of price stabilization we'd
like to explore some of your theories
about the present state of the nation's
business and a nation's economy can you
tell me sir is it true as we read in the
papers that we're in a state of
recession at the present time well I
think that depends on what you're
looking at the answer is yes if you're
talking about the civilian economy that
is automobiles building tech stones
apparel the answer is no if you're
talking about war industries because war
production continues to expand well how
about we people who work and neither the
heavy industries nor the war industries
well you fellows in the financial field
writers are doing just about all right
there's been no special recession or
expansion there are you telling our
audience sir that if it were not for war
industry now and the
man's of the rearmament program that the
country might well be in a serious
recession whatever how serious it would
be mr. Huey but I am convinced that we
have a considerably larger amount of
unemployment we have lower prices we
have less inflation and we have less
demand generally we'd have a condition
which would look as good as it does
today now you're saying that in the war
industries things are holding well where
is business worse in the country now
well I guess we get the most complaints
and justifiably from the textile
industry and from apparel the television
and appliance industry hasn't been doing
too well these days you know if you walk
into one of these appoints towards
almost impossible to get out at any
price very recently they remove the
credit restrictions they removed
regulation w which means that anyone can
go in and charge things and pay for them
over a longer period of time do you
think that that will help the television
and appliance industry and perhaps e
apparel industry as well I think it will
help the appliance industry a little but
the real reason why appliances have not
been selling is that the fellow who
bought himself a television set a year
ago instead of waiting until he thought
he could afford it in 1952 just doesn't
buy it now in other words when the war
broke out in Korea many people rushed
out to buy scare buying scare buying and
part of the problem we faced is that
people have not been undertaking that
type of buying now and I haven't doing a
normal bar the retailer is paying now
for what they reaped back right after
the Korean War yes they are and I think
if you look at the figures you'll find
that the extra amount is selling at that
time is just about equal to the smaller
amount of selling now it's sort of
cancel it is a sort of cancel out the
public the public demand for goods is
now going down is that correct sir I
think the public demand for goods has
gone down a little whether it's going
down at this moment is difficult to say
it seems to be sort of stabilizing at a
lower level when we had a year ago and
our our audience is particularly
interested in prices now what about
prices are they on their way down well
that's fall we've had some good
hints as to what may happen prices at
retail usually are the last to fall but
I'm happy to say that it wholesale they
have declined and we've already had a
considerable number of announcements of
lower prices for appliances for clothing
I guess about everything except fresh
fruits and vegetable and rents now you
say you're happy to say that sir it in
other words do you regard it as a good
omen is good for the American people for
prices to come down what was the Huey
when you see what the dollarboyz any a
step in the direction of buying a little
bit more as a good omen in other words
sir you you feel that it is perhaps a
good sign if the wholesaler and the
retailer do not make so much profit it's
not only a question of how much profit
they make it's a question of what we
have to pay when we walk into a store
now if they sell a large volume of goods
they can make money even though they
don't make as much on each unit call a
turnover now in this period where the
war industries are holding but where
prices are coming down who are the best
paid people the best paid workers in the
American economy now well the best paid
workers generally our co-workers steel
workers construction workers Automobile
Workers they generally run anywhere from
25 to 50 cents above the average for all
manufacturing industries aren't these
the very workers will create most of the
labor strife looking for more higher
increases in pay they usually in the
forefront well now why is that sir why
are these industries are they to blame
for it who's to blame for the fact that
they they continually seek higher wages
well many of these workers are in
industries which are essential to the
war effort and when something is scarce
as laborers in those industries you go
out and try and get it in other words
these are the people that have they are
in the best bargaining position to get
higher wages well yes look at the
contrast between the textile workers who
are fighting to stay in the same place
and say steel workers who are fighting
the chump way ahead the textile industry
isn't doing too well the steel industry
move
the capacity in other words it's a it's
an effort on the part of the steel
industry to take advantage of the war
situation to get a higher wage scale for
themselves we were still workers yeah I
thinks if that's the case when there's a
shortage of workers they try to get more
when is it so plus they just don't get
more for example in 1949 they didn't get
wage increases largely because business
conditions were sort of sadly known
supply and demand working on the labor
side very definitely but don't you feel
however that the textile in the textile
industry particularly they're just
waiting for the steel issue to be
settled well it's difficult to talk for
the textile industry but from what I've
been able to find out about it they're
hoping they can get the same contracts
they had before Chris business has been
pretty bad in that area now dr. Backman
our audience has heard a great many
experts on the steel controversy now as
some of them said they were speaking for
the people some for the government we've
had this label spokesman for industry
you're perhaps could qualify as being
objective now can you how would you
simplify the present steel controversy
for our audience well I'd say one thing
we'd want to know is what is the
economic position of the steelworkers
how much money are they making compared
with other workers who was talking to
Jerry Moore well that's one aspect the
other question is how much a lower wages
increased recently well now we've had a
mr. arnel and others have talked about
to catch up that it was necessary for
the steel industry now to precipitate a
crisis so that they could catch up now
what are they catching up to well that's
something I have not been able to find
out if you look at the figures they look
something like this the steelworkers run
in the top ten or fifteen percent of
workers in terms of wages in the economy
if you go back to almost any date you
want go back to nineteen fifty-nine they
made twenty cents an hour more than all
manufacturing workers go back to the end
of the war they made twenty cents an
hour more go back to the beginning of
nineteen fifty before career they made
24 cents more you look at the figures
today they're making 24 cents more I
think what happened is this when the
steel industry and the work is agreed to
an increase last year temporarily steel
workers got up to a spread of as much
33 cents then when the other workers
caught up to steal they came back to
this 24 cents spread and that's where
they are today and if steel workers get
an increase I think it's pretty clear as
to what will happen with other workers
the others will go ahead with them well
John elois seems to be waiting aluminum
retailers you can go right down the line
all right industries now when mr. Ellis
Arnall the economic stabilizer was on
this program he said that if the steel
industry was given its price increases
it would cost the average American
family about four hundred dollars a year
because the prices of other metals and
other services other supplies would go
up along with steel which perhaps was
logical reasoning but we never did
explore the other side suppose the steel
workers are given their wage increases
what will that cost the american family
per year whether the steel industry gets
a price increase or not Americans
generally going to pay for the steel
wage increase if the steel industry gets
no price increase it will mean that the
tax collections of the government will
fall and if that increased spreads
throughout the economy that fall in tax
collections will run over five billion
dollars a year and I might add that runs
well over a hundred dollars for every
family in the country in other words
every family in the country will pay
over a hundred dollars a year for the
steel wage increases they'll have to pay
it either in the form of higher taxes if
the government was collect more taxes
that will let me make this point clear
if the government pays for this wage
increase out of tax revenues yes whether
we get a tax increase or not the
American people will pay because the
fundamental a basic source of inflation
this business of somebody reaching his
hand into your pocket and taking
something out is the government spending
more than it takes in and the major
effect of no price increase in steel
will be that the government will spend
even more than it expects to in
relationship to what it takes in all
right in the face of all this mr.
Bachman dr. Bergman we are d controlling
we are removing controls from our
economy we are allowing credit
controls to be removed we are allowing
price controls to be removed we are
permitting steel to be used as much as
people want to use it aluminum so on and
so forth do you find any significance in
this trend well it's interesting to me
to find the administration going to
Congress and saying they need a type
price control law at a time when they
are lifting controls and at a time when
they are getting rid of credit controls
which are really basic to the whole
problem of price rises and inflation of
course it's an election year that might
have something to do with it well dr.
Beckmann I'm very much sure I'm sure
that our audience fear much appreciate
your views and thank you sir for being
with us the editorial board for this
edition of the lawn gene Cronus cope was
mister william bradford huie and mr.
Donald I Rogers our distinguished guest
was dr. Jules Backman professor of
economics of New York University